New York City expects more than three
and a half million people for this
morning's Thanksgiving Day Parade and
thousands of police officers with
state-of-the-art equipment are there two
heavily armed NYPD officers are
patrolling the parade route snipers are
watching from buildings above New York
Mayor Bill de Blasio says there's no
specific credible threat to the city or
the parade DeMarco Morgan is near the
parade starting point along New York
Central Park with the intense security
effort demarco good morning good morning
guys the floats are ready to go and so
our law enforcement recent terror
attacks here in the city across the
country and across the entire world have
now shaped the way millions of people
will take in this annual tradition fans
big and small lied to the streets of
Manhattan on Wednesday to watch the
annual inflation of the balloons before
the parade there's so many and they're
gigantic
yeah it's really fun but it's cool too
for the first time this event took place
during the day and bags were checked
just a couple of the security updates to
one of the country's largest soft target
exposed areas with large crowds the
nation's largest police force says it is
ready for any potential threat we look
at what's going on around the world and
we make changes and we adapt to
different things that have happened
throughout the world not just this
country the NYPD has been working with
hotels along the parade route a new
measure taken after a gunman opened fire
at a concert in Las Vegas from his hotel
room in October 58 died about five
hundred were injured we trained the
hotel personnel what to look for watch
suspicious and we get information and we
follow up on leads well the second year
in a row heavy-duty trucks will be used
to block the route from a possible
vehicle attack just last month a terrace
used a truck and lower Manhattan to kill
eight people and injured more than a
dozen local state and federal agencies
will fill this command center watching
the multitude of cameras set up
throughout the city people working in
this office can move them manipulate
them focus in on areas I have all the
faith in the world that our men and
women will keep
this event very safe now the City
Commission to two thousand more police
officers on patrol than in previous
years what officials are saying if you
see something say something Alex
DeMarco thanks